- Une impression dent des mients
devant le monument national pour
qu'il y ait un meilleur contrôle
des armes à feu.re
fraîche dans les esprits
et ne passe pas.
Le 24 mai, un étudiant
de 18 ans tue 19 écolierses
dans une école primaireau Texas.
"De minuscules cercueils,
dit-il, des petides petides pets
et décapités."
L'image est poignante
"C'est bouleversant",
dit Claire Fallender,
qui a des enfants du même
interdire
les fusils d'assaut" dit-elle
"et vérifier les antécédents, bd
presque tous la-dessus."
"Je suisdit-elledit-elledit-elle
de penser à des armes à feu
en classe et je ne veux pas
apprendre à savoir tirer."
te", dit-elle,
"on doit les poursuivre,
ils sont responsables de cette
à feu, ils font de la promotion,
les fabricants d'armes
avec leurs armes."
,
un mémorial, un triste rappeldes
sous les balles : plus de 45 000
des suicides.
Une fois de plus,
les Américains lancent
pour mettre un terme à toutescÉ.
Ils espèrent que cette colère
va se traduire par une loiestree
une fois pour toutes
s aux armes à feu.
La balle est dans le camp du
Sénat. Plusieurs projets de loi
drapeau rouge, qui permettrait
la saiaire d'armes
à feu lorsqu'elles appartiennent
à une p
et dangereuse.
dans mon quartier", dit Robert,
"mais depuis que j
des coups de feu,
je reste chez moi."
au Sénat, ces jeunes de 12 ans
subissen de l'inaction
au congrès.
Ici Azeb Wolde-Gi